that's what has driven these different
responses and guesses but i am working
at hello everybody my name is nyan i'm
the black female engineer i provide
content for new
and aspiring software engineers and
today i
just finished my first day at my new
job literally just finished it is 6
p.m exactly my time pacific time i'm in
los
angeles and i i'm still at my desk
like i just finished and oh my goodness
y'all i am tired i am
i'm quite tired um and so i was like hey
let's
film this that way everything's still
fresh and whatnot
but no i started off the day really just
trying to figure out my systems and
logins and whatnot typically when you do
start a new job
before you even start the team is
prepping your arrival by making sure
they have everything set up for you
this includes logins and emails and any
other accounts whether they be internal
or external
really setting that up for you and
sometimes you can actually access them
before you even start working but they
try to
have you not do that because you're not
getting paid to read these emails like
don't access them but i didn't get to
access them
over the last few weeks so last week
was orientation not team specific
orientation more about company-wide
orientation of these are our
values this is these trainings of you
know anti-discrimination anti-harassment
um security protocols things like that
and so i really didn't get any insight
into
my job and my team it really was very
separated from
my team and so here i come today really
struggling
to get access to my accounts my email
accounts
my yeah just other portals and i got
into this
really big i don't even know like jumble
because
to access let's see like the vpn so i
can
work on things even though i'm working
from home i'm not actually
actually at the physical site i needed
my email
login but then my email login is locked
out and so i can't access that and so
it became this whole big jumbled mess
and so i spent most of my
morning doing that if you're not
you know like me as blessed as i am you
will go through your morning more
swimmingly and will instead really just
focus on reading emails and looking at
your calendar
and seeing what touch bases or chats you
have scheduled for
the day i got to talk face-to-face
you know screen to screen with my
manager for the first time
today which was so exciting especially
because i don't know we've been emailing
back and forth
a little bit i think we've only
exchanged maybe three
four email threads over the last maybe
four three months and so i had this kind
of idea
of this person and says nice to actually
finally put a
face to the emails to this account
and so that was really fun and really i
highly recommend taking that time to ask
anything you want because y'all they
expect you to know
nothing so i just know nothing and that
is a great
thing for you because it means there
truly are no dumb questions
like ask whatever and so
i took that time to ask for more of a
rundown of what the team
does for those of you who have been
following my journey for a while you
know that i knew i had a job
but i didn't know what team i would be
on for the longest time
this happens a lot when especially if
you're like
me who applied to a job via university
hires
instead of applying to scrum master
id 54862 at this location
this team and so that wasn't me i
applied to the company as a whole
as a entry-level developer that was
it and so i got that job but now i had
months where i know i have a job and i
know
when i start but i just didn't know
where
or what i'd be doing even what what tech
i'd be using even it was very very
vague because of that as i took that
time with my manager to really just ask
like yo
what do you all do like can you please
give me a rundown
of this team as a whole and then
your role on the team what do you want
and expect my role to be on the team how
i can contribute what your goals are
what your day-to-day procedures are
and yeah what like let's get to knowing
each other i'm very glad i asked that
because
then for the next like five to ten
minutes he
really really went in going into the
products they use and their workflows
and
what things to look out for in the
future
and my part in all of it and i'm the
kind of person who
i need to know i need to know now
even if it's not relevant for the next
six months a year
i want all the information as soon as
possible so him
giving me the rundown of okay so in a
few weeks when you're done with
trainings
you're going to be on this project and
then that after that
this is what i
foresee in the next few months for you
and
us and the team and so i really am glad
i just straight up as like
what time of day is it like what what
what is it
what is this team what am i in this team
just please
share with the class and so then i also
asked what his management style
was this is another thing i highly
highly recommend and so he said straight
up hey i'm not a micro
manager i expect you to get your work
done you know you wouldn't be here if
you are not the type to get your work
done and so that's what i expect
and i prefer this type of communication
and i expect
for you to hear from me from this times
to this time
this is when i'm most available and
whatnot and this is when i expect you to
be most available
and all the sorts we also went into okay
how do
you get and provide feedback because
that is a big thing for me
i like feedback i like to know what i'm
doing well
and what things i can improve upon but
the delivery matters you know i
i'm the person that the delivery matters
especially because
i'm the type of person to be so in my
head
about whether or not i'm doing a good
job and so if i
get anything that indicates i'm not
i kind of internally
combust a little bit and so
he was like no this is how i receive
feedback this is how i give it
and so it was nice to have that heads up
that way
i know what to expect you know what i
mean that way
if you get feedback at two o'clock in
the morning via email
you don't combust you don't
panic because you heard from day one
that he stays up at night and
then he provides all his feedbacks at
once via email
and all that that's not what let me make
it clear that's not what he said to me
i'm just giving an example of why it's
beneficial to ask those kinds of
questions
on day one and yeah after me and him
touched base that was in the afternoon i
went on to
the other trainings i had mostly
more managerial slash company
wide slash i don't even know how i would
explain it just more generic trainings
like this
is how we use email this is the internal
portals we use and whatnot
but as the days and weeks go on the
trainings will become more specified to
talk about my specific languages my
specific
frameworks and things i need to know for
the specific role
i for the next couple of months will be
primarily using python and javascript
however
as my time here goes on
i'll also be using java and c plus plus
oh shoot what was it was it c plus or c
sharp
okay just checked it's c plus plus and
so
i expect those to be a bit more of a
learning curve than
javascript which i've used all this time
in python i'm actually very excited to
start using python i tried to learn
python
about a year ago when i was first
learning how to code however since i had
nothing to tie it back to
it just fell off i just couldn't
continue learning because
all the ideas were so very abstract and
so now that i have a
specific thing to tie it to a specific
role specific workflow specific product
i'm tying it to
i'm very excited to start learning it
again and so where do i work y'all some
of y'all have
guessed i have had guesses for disney
and
dreamworks and sony and and i think you
know me saying
i'm in la and i'm working in like more
like entertainment
and like animations in past videos
that's what has driven
these different responses and guesses
but
i am working at
dreamworks i am working at dreamers
animations in the products engineering
team i am so
excited so excited i just can't imagine
how much i'm going to learn in these
next few days and weeks and months i'm
so so so pumped and so yeah in the next
few
days weeks and months you're going to be
hearing from me a lot about
um just this whole journey i really want
to take you all
as much into it as possible especially
because
this journey i've i've tried my best to
stay
up to date with my life and so i'm
excited to
now provide more day by day real time
updates instead of me sharing oh this is
what i did
x amount of months ago and so i'm very
excited i hope you are too
but if there's anything specific you'd
like to know about me my job
anything uh being in la anything please
let me know in the comments if you want
to make sure i tailor this channel to
the things that
you all want to see from me and so
please please please let me know in the
comments help me help you y'all please
so now i'll see y'all later and yeah
thank you so much for watching don't
forget to like and subscribe
okay thank you bye